have to talk to you about the view yeah
we got to do it sorry uh a lot of you
enjoyed yesterday's show uh some of my
language uh michael you particularly
enjoyed my language around the ladies of
the view i got a lot of text yesterday
people that were watching it like having
lunch like cracking up over some of the
things that i said about those crazy
harpies um but uh what you you know what
happened basically a couple days ago uh
whoopi and the ladies of the view uh
accused turning point at their student
action summit which i was at and ron
desantis was at and president trump was
at and greg gutfeld was that and plenty
of other people were at charlie kirk of
course uh which was all about freedom
and laissez-faire economics and being
proud of america and individual rights
and all of that you know crazy far-right
stuff uh whoopi accused them of
embracing and welcoming in
neo-nazis on the show the other day then
they went to commercial break the
lawyers obviously freaked out whoopi
gave this very half-assed apology saying
that she meant it metaphorically that
they welcomed them in not literally
which actually made no sense and in some
ways made it even worse that they were
because if you're metaphorically
welcoming in nazis it's
irrelevant whether you're welcome into
the building you're sort of doing it
with everything else that you got you're
doing it spiritually which of course is
complete nonsense turning point was
turning them away the students were
mocking them several of the speeches
were making fun of those very same
collectivist ideas anyway the view
really really stepped in it and it was
the thing
online yesterday so then the view now
has had to issue even a further
apology because whoopi's metaphorical
apology didn't quite cut it here is
sarah haynes of the view trying to
unstep in
s-h-i-t
everybody and i have to stop talking
because you have that i do have sorry so
on monday we talked about the fact that
there were openly neo-nazi demonstrators
outside the florida student action
summit of the turning point usa group we
want to make clear that these
demonstrate demonstrators were gathered
outside the event and that they were not
invited or endorsed by turning point usa
a turning point usa spokesman said the
group
100 condemns those ideologies and said
turning point usa security tried to
remove the neo-nazis from the area but
could not because they were on public
property also turning point usa wanted
to clarify i wanted us to clarify that
this was a turning point usa summit and
not a republican party event so we
apologize for anything we said that may
have been unclear on these points they
still invited matt gates though i would
just like to know
uh
just at the end there they still invited
matt gates so is the are they gonna have
to issue another apology because the
implication of course is that matt gates
is a nazi anyway there's just something
interesting about this just something
interesting about these people who throw
out these bombs oh those people are
nazis and they're associated with you
and even if you have nothing to do with
them we're going to make these baseless
accusations we're going to tar all of
you make sure you're not invited to
polite society and then finally
finally what is starting to happen is
people on the right are fighting back it
has taken a long time but finally
somebody at turning point obviously made
a call to a lawyer and one lawyer called
another lawyer and that lawyer over at
abc picked up the phone and said uh oh
we we are in it if we don't issue
another apology so then there's another
just half-assed disingenuous apology and
of course whoopi didn't actually make
the apology uh nor joy behar who implied
that ron desantis was working with the
nazis i mean it's all just silliness
nonsense but i thought it was worth
putting a cap on that after yesterday's
big show